so now your focus shifts from sort of
deliberately learning the language to
you know consuming a lot of interesting
compelling
content in that language hi there steve
kaufman here um today again i'm going to
do this question and answer thing that i
did last week people seem to enjoy it
i am able to deal with a number of
different subjects uh remember if you
enjoy these
videos please subscribe click on the
bell for notification and if you listen
to me on podcast apple podcast or
spotify or wherever
uh please re leave a review
i'll make sure we put links to those
podcasts in the description box
so without further ado and here my
people seem to like these glasses
they're clickable glasses i googled i
bought two pair i have one pair down in
palm springs one pair up here they're
quite inexpensive and they're you know
different strengths 1.52 or whatever you
need for reading
so
now here are the questions that i got
uh yakiti fak says gujarati has been
awesome to study blah blah blah when the
joy dwindles i switched to french so
the point here is that we have gujarati
at link i don't know how many people are
studying it i'm not i may one day it's
not the major indian language but
someone volunteered to do the
mini stories and that's our condition
for adding a new language
uh it's also interesting that
having a major and a minor language
sometimes can be good for
maintaining interest
i'm struggling a bit right now because i
have my persian and my arabic and i've
even started into
egyptian arabic so i've got three sort
of languages bouncing around that there
was some suggestion that i might do a
video
with
a russian person who lives in turkey and
so i went back and tried to refresh my
turkish so all these languages bouncing
around in your brain is an obstacle it
is confusing
but it also is this element of things
new and interesting and uh
you know i'm a dilettante so i enjoy
doing that i think uh yakiti pak is
doing it for fun obviously if you're
going to go for ielts or something uh
toeic then you really want to focus on
one language
all right
next person capacitor says
the problem is that when you reach an
advanced
level it becomes more difficult to learn
more because you already know so much
and this thus it becomes more difficult
to stay motivated with the learning
process well of course
i mean i've said it many times the word
frequency declines
very very steeply so the more words you
learn
the more difficult it is to learn new
words because these new words will
appear less and less frequently in
whatever you're listening to or reading
so
you know i've sometimes said that when
we start in a language we have that
initial i talk about the upside down
hockey stick we have that initial period
where wow we're learning a lot of words
because the most frequent words show up
so often and all of a sudden we
understand some things
and you know we can even say a few
things but then we discovered that
there's actually a long road before you
reach sort of a decent level of fluency
because
unfortunately we need a lot of words
to understand books to understand movies
to even understand conversations that
native speakers are having because
native speakers actually have a lot of
words because they've been with that
language since they were kids and they
say as a rule of thumb that you add a
thousand words for every year of your
life so someone who's 40 years old has
40 000 words so
as a learner to acquire all these words
it takes a long time the secret
therefore is to not be so conscious
of the words you're acquiring and
forgetting and reacquiring and
re-forgetting but if you can find
content of interest that you are
motivated by learning about the country
or learning about some aspect of the
country or even some subject that may
not even be related to the country but
it's a subject of interest to you and
you're learning it in the language that
you're trying to learn so now your focus
shifts from sort of deliberately
learning the language to
you know consuming a lot of interesting
compelling
content in that language
and i did say earlier that it's
difficult to start with compelling
content but when you reach the level of
where you already know a lot of words
the content has to be compelling or it's
hard to continue even though as i also
said i sometimes go back to my many
stories especially if i'm preparing to
speak and to use the language because
that helps me to train it's kind of like
my gym it's my core exercises but yeah
you need that compelling input in order
to keep going for sure
granback says i have a question for
people who learn the language while
living in the country
where the target language was spoken
been learning english i don't have a
chance to use spoken language currently
i'm going to go to germany my level is
a1 i'm wondering whether learning will
be easier and faster because of the
environment of german native speakers
all right
a warning i have always found that when
you go to the country where the language
is spoken you have to have a level
of
b1b almost b2
in order to take advantage
uh because not everyone you deal with in
a shop or on the street and of course
this depends on the level of
your language or a language that you
know
what that level is in the country so if
you go to germany where the level of
english is quite good
uh the average person you encounter will
have a level of english that is higher
than a1
so you either you have to find people
who have
practically no
english and they will then humor you in
german
or you have to get a teacher
so my advice always is to do as much as
you can before you go
and even when you are in the country you
have to work hard on your input
activities so when i lived in japan
i did a lot of listening and reading
this is of course 45 years ago
on my own because the amount that i was
able to use
you know in the early stages was very
limited
so you can't rely on being surrounded by
the by the language of course you turn
on the tv you can listen to the radio
you can read newspapers all of that
which you can do in your home country
too
in whatever language you're learning
but the more you can build it up before
you get there
and the more you continue your input
activities so that you can get yourself
up to almost a i would say be one and a
half in terms of your comprehension the
better you're going to do and the more
likely people will speak to you in the
language you're learning in the target
language
so max says
uh
what do i have to do in order to take
ielts or toefl if i'm learning on my own
what kind of techniques all right so
many people need these
tests of english like ielts and toefl
they need them to get into a good school
or they need them for work
my feeling is that you can get copies of
those tests so that you have some sense
of what the tests are all about you can
even do
you know
example tests all of this material is
available on the internet but
fundamentally you have to raise up your
overall language skills you have to
become a better reader you have to read
fast or you're going to run out of time
in the test so again it comes back to
listening and reading personally i think
link is a great way to work on toeic or
ielts because it's it's all about
comprehension
vocabulary
and you listen to so much and you read
so much that you have you get a better
sense of what's correct grammar and not
correct grammar you don't have to
scratch your brain as much and many of
those
questions on those tests comprehension
questions or questions about what is
correct and not correct usage if you if
you can read quickly and if you can
understand well for the parts where you
have to listen to
content the better you comprehend the
better you understand the better you're
going to do the better your feel for the
language the better you're going to do i
don't think it's that useful
to study you know the 5 000 words that
will show up in toeic you can do that
and there's nothing wrong with doing
that but it should be done against the
backdrop backdrop of having elevated
your overall level in the language
listening comprehension reading skills
vocabulary
uh okay
what about reading the dictionary from
page from the front to the back it's not
something that i would do
uh
you know it's one of these activities
it's like studying a list of words
um
you know
you think you're doing something you
think you're learning i don't think
you're learning very much
so it can be interesting and if you see
a lot of words that you already kind of
have know it can sort of reinforce what
you are still trying to learn
but i i don't think it's a
tremendous strategy and it's hard to
keep doing
but
any exposure to the language is good
no
here's this question my problem problem
he says is finding out
he learns the conjugations in spanish
but how are they used you know keria or
kise in other words the different past
forms well this is true in any language
in english
when do we say i
i have done it i did it
uh
simple past versus the sort of whatever
it's called in english that compose
these are things that have to do with
usage and it's not just when you use
these different conjugation forms it's
even a matter of which words are used
together with which other words word
usage word usage
these are this is a matter of developing
habits in the language and i believe
that a lot of listening and reading
hearing the language starts to create
patterns in your brain so certain forms
certain conjugation forms are going to
seem more natural also
there are always sort of trigger words
that trigger the tense because we're
here talking about tenses in the case of
this conjugation form and so you know
just now i did okay just now suggest
simple past
uh while uh
while i was watching tv i was also so
the wild tends to suggest a more
continuous form sort of the imperfect so
you should look at words that surround
these different tenses whether it's in
spanish or english or any other language
and you will see that certain tenses are
suggested by certain trigger words and
you should notice those and maybe save
them at link and all of this helps you
notice and once you notice things you
can develop
the proper language habits so that the
usage will seem more natural that
doesn't mean you'll always get it right
and in many cases it may not even matter
which you use
uh in english sometimes it's just best
to use the simple past can't go wrong
kind of thing
but you want to develop a feel and
that's only achieved through lots of
listening and reading and and eventually
using the language
um so
como puede initia con la mandarin
starting in mandarin is the same as
everything else except you have to learn
the characters what do you think about
negative motivation like if people
aren't nice to you you know he goes on
uh make fun of immigrant students and
stuff i mean you have to turn that off
like there are going to be nasty people
in this world there are people who will
make fun of you
in any situation not just having to do
with language and you can't take these
things too seriously the majority of
people are nice the majority of people
are encouraging some people are not and
i just turn off the people who are i i
have a very selective memory when i was
in japan everyone was nice to me that
doesn't mean everyone was nice to me
that means i only remember the people
who were nice to me and i think you have
to focus on the positive
um you talk about reading reading
reading but do you do this silently or
at la out loud okay
reading i read i i think i'm reading
silently
and i'll often depending on where i am
in the language i will listen while i'm
reading
i think when we learn another language
when we're reading we're all so
sub-vocalizing because when we read our
own language it's instant meaning we
don't need to sub-vocalize we don't need
to say it to ourselves but when we're
reading in a foreign language i find
that i'm saying it to myself but i very
rarely read out loud out loud it's
tiring but i tend to sub-vocalize and
that's why combining listening with
reading is so important because it gives
you that momentum it gives you that
sense it gives you greater confidence
that you are sub-vocalizing
with the right pronunciation and the
right intonation
a person says i never thought of
listening while exercising i mean come
on you can listen while you're doing
anything washing the dishes driving a
car exercising working in the garden you
name it someone here says that the voice
is too low i've had this comment before
i i don't know
i think when i listen to my videos the
audio sounds fine please let me know if
the audio is a problem
here's what we call a soft question what
is the best app or program to learn a
new language well of course i'm going to
say link
l-i-n-g-q
and finally here's one from nikita
who says uh how do you go with the
self-limited vocabulary
in german when i read interesting stuff
i don't understand it so this is
constant issue of you know the beginner
stuff is easy because
the word frequency declines very quickly
so in an initial period you have
content with a lot of high frequency uh
words like our mini stories and then as
you move into natural content of course
now all of a sudden you're dealing with
far more low frequency words so what do
you do well it's a bit of a struggle
i believe that that the lack of
intermediate content is a problem in
many languages i experience it in arabic
and in persian that's where i'm grateful
to sarah who has created a lot of
excellent content in persian i've
mentioned you know fonseo tauntiq or
inner french which are great sources of
intermediate content in french
but it is a problem and i think at link
for example if i can find content that
has 10 15 new words that's a comfort
zone there i'm learning a lot of new
words because some of those 10 15 are in
fact names so it's actually less than
that
and so that to me is good content i'm
coming across new words and yet i have
enough
known words that it's not painful
but i have gone through russian for
example at the early days when i was
with russian and link was much slower
than it is now and i had material with
40 new words and i just fought on
because i wanted to learn this language
and i was interested in whatever it was
that i was reading it could have been
you know a tolstoy or something
and i just struggled on so it's a
function of our you know our pain
threshold
so and and i tend to find myself
bouncing back and forth i fight my way
through difficult content lots of new
words and ah i'm tired of doing that i
get back to my mini stores and this kind
of gives me a little more confidence and
then i go back and fight with more
difficult content and you just have to
find a proper
mix of easy content and difficult
content so that you maintain your
motivation you get enough fluency
because you're dealing with easier
content and yet you're acquiring new
words and you're fighting away fighting
your way through to
eventually getting enough vocabulary so
that you can deal with more authentic
content more easily okay i'm just going
to deal with those questions today i
hope that was of interest i see i've
gone on a bit longer um
leave you a few videos kind of
related to this and let me know if this
is of interest to you
thank you bye for now